-Making his TV debut
performing "Masterpiece"
from his new album, "Mob,"
give it up for Babyface Ray!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Pooh, you a fool for this one.
[ Echoing ]
Pooh, you a fool for this one.
♪♪
-Yeah.
-[ Rapping ]
♪ I'm trying to take off
like a rocket ship ♪
♪ She told me boy put down that
cup, cuz its killing you ♪
♪ Got some advice
from my doctor chick. ♪
♪ I made a blueprint
in this speed ♪
♪ My guys, it feels like
my biggest accomplishment ♪
♪ I roll from the trenches,
just boys in the hood ♪
♪ And I ride for my boys
like monster did. ♪
♪ You working, I'm working too ♪
♪ Sunday I'm cleaning
my dirty shoes. ♪
♪ I took brodie clothes,
and I went to school. ♪
♪ That money cant help you
forget the truth. ♪
♪ Just knock down your shots
when you hit your move ♪
♪ The bands in my pocket
got me switching moves ♪
♪ This ain't right,
so dis is groovy ♪
♪ They telling me stuff
that I'm telling you ♪
♪ Just follow your gut
what I'm telling you ♪
♪ I went to the game
with my chains on ♪
♪ Something wish I never knew ♪
♪ That money machine,
my ringtone ♪
♪ You know how it is,
you know how it get ♪
♪ Just make sure you're
living with zero regrets ♪
♪ I look in the mirror and
couldn't notice myself ♪
♪ When my pockets were bulging
and polo my belt, for real ♪
♪ Big body beamer when
I'm scraping these streets ♪
♪ Left wrist Picasso,
masterpiece ♪
♪ Fremont woods,
And it has to be ♪
♪ I know God got plans for me ♪
♪ No opps --
like faster than me ♪
♪ Rap game still got
bags for cheap ♪
♪ You, up that's doing
bad to me ♪
♪ I don't flex bands,
I'm stashing these ♪
♪ Big body beamer when
I'm scraping these streets ♪
♪ Left wrist Picasso,
masterpiece ♪
♪ Fremont woods,
and it has to be ♪
♪ I know God got plans for me ♪
♪ No opps --
like faster than me ♪
♪ Rap game still got
bags for cheap ♪
♪ Yo, up that's doing
bad to me ♪
♪ I don't flex bands,
I'm stashing these ♪
♪ You working, I'm working too ♪
♪ that girl that you with
just a -- ♪
♪ She just works for food
I'm thirsty for purple juice ♪
♪ I can get 60
for perky for 30 blue ♪
♪ I need me a turtle, too ♪
♪ I'm blowing on gas, my prices
be raising, like, everyday ♪
♪ Pimping, made money
off Mary Jay ♪
♪ Turn up the tracks,
in figure 8 ♪
♪ I had to visit my jeweler,
he told me I'm cooler ♪
♪ Than all this ice in here ♪
♪ Man, my whole life
been a movie ♪
♪ I traveled the world, and I
make sure the price was fair ♪
♪ You know it's -- game
I'm keeping it on me ♪
♪ They thought I had
license to carry ♪
♪ You know its pure in my heart
but my family be dark ♪
♪ They guiding my spirit, yeah ♪
♪ No cut too raw
for their ears ♪
♪ No cups on imma switch 'em
for diamonds ♪
♪ Time is money, this -- ♪
♪ Thousands investing
in watches ♪
♪ I ain't dealing with houses ♪
♪ I'm off g6 with two girls
in the shower ♪
♪ We on g6's,
they over the clouds ♪
♪ First I was sleep,
but I'm over and out ♪
♪ I had to tell baby,
you know what I got, ♪
♪ You know where I come from ♪
♪ I ain't buying no tickets
these boys be selling ♪
♪ I know they ain't
dealing nothing ♪
♪ You get it,
just keep it all to yourself ♪
♪ I'm keeping it one hunnit ♪
♪ Exclusive youngin,
I'm tight with the birds ♪
♪ I'm feeling like young money ♪
♪ You know how I get ♪
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪